welcome to CS 256 mobile web development
we're here to teach you to apply your
web development skills to this and to
this because as you're probably aware
the mobile web is kind of a big deal
most statistics project that mobile web
usage will soon overtake desktop web
usage so you might ask what's the
difference between developing for the
desktop web and developing for the
mobile web
well mobile web development is really
just normal web development with some
additional key considerations and a few
additional api's we're going to assume
that you're familiar with the building
blocks of HTML CSS and JavaScript the
mobile web is also built on these
technologies although we are going to
cover some specific advanced features
that apply to the mobile space of course
there are a lot of additional
considerations for developing for mobile
things like smaller screen sizes and
limited network bandwidth and computing
power while you might think these
constraints are a bad thing
in fact developing mobile first forces
you to focus on the key points of your
user experience